Wir alle brauchen die Möglichkeit, private Informationen auszutauschen, ohne Angst haben zu müssen,
dass jemand mithört. Aber ein narrensicheres System dafür zu entwickeln ist gar nicht so einfach.
In der heutigen Folge von Kisket im Klassenzimmer sprechen wir darüber, wie etwas namens
Quantenschlüsselverteilung dabei helfen kann.
Willkommen zurück bei Kisket im Klassenzimmer. In dieser Serie behandeln wir Themen, die du
in einem quantencomputerbezogenen Universitätskurs begegnen könntest. Zu jedem Video gibt es ein interaktives Modul,
das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist – schau es dir unbedingt an.
Heute tauchen wir in die Welt der Quantenkryptografie ein. Kryptografie ist die Wissenschaft von Techniken
für sichere Kommunikation. Das ist für viele Bereiche unseres Lebens unglaublich wichtig.
Jedes Mal, wenn du ein Passwort verwendest, um dich bei einer Website anzumelden, eine digitale Zahlung sendest oder wenn
Regierungen militärische Informationen übermitteln – das alles läuft über kryptografische Protokolle,
damit ein Lauscher unsere Geheimnisse nicht erfahren kann. Aber es gibt hier eine Spannung.
Wie stellen wir sicher, dass die Person, mit der wir kommunizieren wollen, unsere Nachricht versteht,
aber niemand sonst? Historisch gesehen haben Kryptografen viele verschiedene Protokolle entwickelt,
um ihre Nachrichten so abhörsicher wie möglich zu machen.
Manchmal einigen sich die beiden Parteien, die sicher kommunizieren wollen, vorab auf einen Code,
der hoffentlich so kompliziert ist, dass ein Lauscher ihn nicht knacken kann.
Aber wie Leute wie Alan Turing und andere Codeknacker aus Kriegszeiten gezeigt haben,
können selbst die kompliziertesten Codes geknackt werden. Im Idealfall würden wir Nachrichten senden, die
so verschlüsselt sind, dass es absolut kein Muster gibt und kein Lauscher sie
verstehen kann – ohne auch einen geheimen Zufallsschlüssel zu besitzen, den nur Sender und Empfänger kennen.
Damit machen wir uns jedoch für eine neue Schwachstelle anfällig. Wie können wir diesen Schlüssel senden und sicher sein,
dass ihn niemand abfängt? Im Jahr 1984 entwickelten Charles Bennett und Jill Brassard eine Methode,
einen Schlüssel mit Quantenbits sicher zu übertragen – heute als BB84 bekannt. Die entscheidende Eigenschaft dieser Quanten-
bits oder qubits, die dieses Protokoll ermöglicht, ist, dass sie der Unschärferelation gehorchen.
Man kann ein Quantensystem nicht messen, ohne es zu stören. Heute beginnen wir mit einem Beispiel
eines einfachen kryptografischen Codes. Dann zeige ich dir, wie Quantenschlüsselverteilung und die Unschärfe-
relation es uns ermöglichen, nahezu unknackbare Verschlüsselungen zu verwenden. Ich führe dich durch das BB84-
Protokoll im Detail, und schließlich führen wir es auf einem echten Quantencomputer aus.
Fangen wir zunächst mit einem Spiel an, das du vielleicht schon kennen könntest: dem Kryptogramm.
Du bekommst eine Folge scheinbar zufälliger Buchstaben, aber durch dein Wissen über Muster in der
englischen Sprache kannst du einen Buchstaben durch einen anderen ersetzen, um die Nachricht zu entziffern. Hier ist
ein Beispiel. Dies ist eine geheime Nachricht mit einer einfachen Substitutions-Chiffre. Alle R's stehen für
einen Buchstaben, M's für einen anderen, und so weiter. Wenn du es selbst versuchen möchtest,
pausiere das Video jetzt. Es stellt sich heraus, dass diese Nachricht mit einer sehr einfachen
Chiffre verschlüsselt wurde: der Caesar-Chiffre, bei der das Alphabet einfach um eine bestimmte Anzahl
verschoben wird – in diesem Fall neun. Also wird A zu J, B zu K, C zu L, und so weiter. Je länger die Nachricht,
desto leichter ist das Muster zu erkennen. Bei einer so langen Nachricht wie der gegebenen
ist die Caesar-Chiffre – oder jede andere Chiffre, die einfach einen Buchstaben des Alphabets durch einen anderen ersetzt –
ziemlich leicht zu knacken. Eine sicherere Methode zur Verschlüsselung einer geheimen Nachricht ist das sogenannte
One-Time-Pad. Mit einem One-Time-Pad kannst du für jeden Buchstaben in der Nachricht eine andere Verschiebung verwenden.
Du musst deiner Freundin oder deinem Freund nur mitteilen, wie groß die Verschiebung bei jedem war, damit sie die Nachricht entschlüsseln können.
Diese Liste von Verschiebungen nennt man den Schlüssel oder das Pad. Es heißt One-Time-Pad, weil es
einmal verwendet und dann verworfen wird. Wird es öfter benutzt, entstehen Muster, die die
Verschlüsselung knackbar machen könnten. Bei der One-Time-Pad-Verschlüsselung sind sowohl die verschlüsselte Nachricht als auch der Schlüssel
für sich genommen nur eine zufällige Zeichenfolge ohne Bedeutung. Aber wenn man sie zusammenfügt, taucht aus dem Rauschen eine geheime
Nachricht auf. Machen wir ein kurzes Beispiel: Angenommen, ich habe bereits ein One-Time-Pad erstellt und an
meine Freundin geschickt – normalerweise in binärer Form geschrieben. Dann möchte ich die Nachricht
„I love quantum" senden. Dann würde ich die Nachricht mit dem One-Time-Pad so verschlüsseln.
Zuerst wandeln wir die Buchstaben unserer Nachricht in Binärform um. Jeder Buchstabe A bis Z entspricht den
Zahlen 1 bis 26 in Binärdarstellung. A ist also 0, 0, 0, 0, 1; B ist 0, 0, 0, 1, 0; C ist
0, 0, 0, 1, 1, und so weiter. Ein Leerzeichen wird durch lauter Nullen dargestellt. Und so sieht die Nachricht dann aus.
Wir verschlüsseln die Nachricht, indem wir ein XOR zwischen jedem Bit der Nachricht und dem entsprechenden
Bit im One-Time-Pad durchführen. Falls du XOR noch nicht kennst: Es steht für „Exklusiv-Oder". Das XOR
zweier Bits ergibt 1, wenn genau eines der Bits 1 ist, und 0, wenn beide 0 oder
beide 1 sind. Die ersten fünf Bits der verschlüsselten Nachricht werden also zu 1, 0, 0, 0, 1, 1.
Die restlichen XOR-Berechnungen überlasse ich dir. Aber der Punkt ist: Diese Nachricht ist nun
nur noch eine zufällige Folge von Nullen und Einsen ohne Muster. Sie ist vollständig unlesbar für
alle, die das One-Time-Pad nicht besitzen, das wir zur Verschlüsselung verwendet haben. Was haben wir also bisher gelernt?
Manche Verschlüsselungsverfahren sind besser als andere, und manche können von cleveren Personen
entschlüsselt werden, die nach Mustern in der verschlüsselten Nachricht suchen. Aber ein wirklich zufälliger Schlüssel, der jeden Buchstaben
einer geheimen Nachricht um einen anderen zufälligen Betrag verschiebt, kann nicht entschlüsselt werden, weil es keine Muster
in der Nachricht gibt. Die einzige Schwachstelle bei einem solchen System ist sicherzustellen, dass der Schlüssel,
der zur Verschlüsselung der Nachricht verwendet wurde, nicht in falsche Hände gerät. Hier kommt die Quantenschlüsselverteilung
ins Spiel. Durch die Verwendung von qubits entwickelten Bennett und Brassard eine Methode, mit der zwei Parteien sich auf einen Schlüssel einigen
und dabei hinreichend sicher sein können, dass keine dritte Partei heimlich lauscht. Dieses BB84-Protokoll
ist etwas kompliziert, aber wir gehen es Schritt für Schritt durch. Für diese Erklärung holen wir
unsere alten Freunde Alice und Bob zurück. Das Protokoll beginnt damit, dass Alice eine Reihe von qubits vorbereitet, die sie an
Bob sendet. Diese qubits enthalten die Informationen, die ihr gemeinsames One-Time-Pad oder ihren Schlüssel bilden werden.
Alice erzeugt zunächst zwei zufällige Sequenzen gleicher Länge. Die erste ist eine zufällige Sequenz von
Nullen und Einsen, und die zweite ist eine zufällige Sequenz von X's und Z's – sie repräsentiert die Basis, in der
sie ihre qubits vorbereiten wird. Dann bereitet sie jeden qubit in einem Quantenzustand vor, gemäß der
Kombination aus Basis und Bitwert, wie in dieser Tabelle gezeigt. Wenn also das Bit null und die Basis
Z ist, bereitet sie den qubit im Nullzustand vor; oder wenn das Bit eins und die Basis X ist,
bereitet sie ihn im Minus-Zustand vor. Falls du dir bei diesen Basen und Quantenzuständen nicht sicher bist,
kein Problem. Der wichtigste Punkt ist, dass Messungen in jeder Basis immer nur zwei
mögliche Ergebnisse haben. Null oder eins für die Z-Basis und Plus oder Minus für die X-Basis. Wenn du den
Nullzustand in der Z-Basis misst, bekommst du immer null. Aber wenn du denselben Zustand in der X-Basis misst,
bekommst du ein zufälliges Ergebnis – entweder Plus oder Minus, jeweils mit 50-prozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Alice könnte also eine Folge von qubits wie diese vorbereiten – hier ist die zufällige Folge aus Nullen und Einsen,
und hier ist die zufällige Folge aus X's und Z's. Das erste Element in jeder ihrer beiden Sequenzen
war null und X. Das bedeutet, dass sie den ersten qubit im Plus-Zustand vorbereiten wird, und so weiter.
Sobald sie alle ihre qubit-Zustände vorbereitet hat, sendet Alice Bob diese qubits, und Bob wählt zufällig
zwischen X und Z als Basis, in der er jeden qubit misst. Wir fügen der Tabelle also einige Zeilen hinzu,
um Bobs Entscheidungen und Messungen darzustellen. Hier sind Bobs Messungen und Basisentscheidungen,
und hier sind seine Messergebnisse der qubits, die Alice ihm gesendet hat. Schließlich kann Bob jede
Messung mithilfe der gleichen Tabelle, die Alice zur Vorbereitung ihrer qubits verwendet hat, in ein Bit umwandeln. Wenn er
den Null- oder Plus-Zustand misst, weist er den Bitwert null zu; wo er den Eins- oder Minus-Zustand misst,
setzt er eine Eins. Bobs endgültige Bitfolge ist diese letzte Zeile.
Man beachte: Wenn die Basis von Alices Vorbereitungsschritt und Bobs Messungsschritt übereinstimmen,
stimmen auch ihre Bits überein. Wenn Alice aber Z zur Vorbereitung wählt und Bob in X misst oder umgekehrt,
müssen Alices und Bobs entsprechende Bits nicht unbedingt gleich sein. Eine Möglichkeit, wie sie sich
auf eine gemeinsame Bitfolge für ihr One-Time-Pad einigen können, ist, einander anzurufen und gegenseitig mitzuteilen,
welche Basis sie für jeden qubit verwendet haben. Wenn die Basen übereinstimmen, behalten sie das Bit. Wenn nicht,
werfen sie es weg. In diesem Fall werden Alice und Bob sich beide auf die Bitfolge null,
null, eins, null, null einigen. Wie schützt das System vor unbemerkt lauschenden Angreifern? Schauen wir uns an,
was passiert, wenn eine solche Lauscherin namens Eve die qubits abfängt, die Alice an Bob sendet.
Sie weiß nicht, in welchem Zustand diese qubits sind oder wie Alice sie vorbereitet hat. Dank der
Unschärferelation und etwas, das als No-Cloning-Theorem bekannt ist, kann sie nicht einfach eine identische
Kopie der qubits anfertigen, um sie an Bob weiterzugeben. Könnte sie es, wäre sie in der Lage, unbemerkt zu lauschen.
Stattdessen rät sie eine Basis, in der sie jeden qubit misst, misst sie,
und bereitet dann einen neuen Satz gefälschter qubits vor, die sie an Bob weitersendet. Es gibt andere, hinterhältigere Methoden,
mit denen Eve versuchen könnte, die qubits auszuspähen, aber keine umgeht die Unschärferelation.
Wir nehmen also diese einfache Lausch-Methode an. Hier ist eine Tabelle, die
Alices Vorbereitung, Eves Abfangen und Bobs finale Messung beschreibt. Wenn Alice und Bob
dann telefonieren und ihre Basen vergleichen, entscheiden sie, diese Bits für ihren Schlüssel zu behalten.
Aber die Bits stimmen nicht überein. Das liegt daran, dass Bob qubits gemessen hat, die Eve vorbereitet hat, nicht die ursprünglichen
qubits von Alice. Wenn sie einen Teil der Bits ihrer Bitfolgen miteinander vergleichen,
werden sie feststellen, dass einige nicht übereinstimmen, und schlussfolgern, dass jemand gelauscht haben muss.
Da Eve entdeckt wurde, werden Alice und Bob ihre Bitfolgen verwerfen und das Protokoll
von vorne beginnen. Wenn Eve aber nicht gelauscht hätte und die verglichenen Bits von Alice und Bob
übereinstimmen würden, könnten sie die verbleibenden Bits, die sie nicht verglichen haben,
als gemeinsamen Schlüssel verwenden. Sobald Alice und Bob einen gemeinsamen Schlüssel haben, kann Alice verschlüsselte Nachrichten an
Bob senden, und Bob ist der Einzige, der sie mit dem Schlüssel entschlüsseln kann. Nachdem wir das
Protokoll durchgegangen sind, versuchen wir es auf einem Quantencomputer. Für dieses
Experiment gibt es ein paar Dinge zu beachten. Erstens ist BB84 wirklich nur dann nützlich, wenn Alice und Bob weit voneinander entfernt sind.
Bei dem Experiment, das wir gleich machen werden, befinden sich Alice und Bob auf demselben Quantenchip. Dieses
Experiment eignet sich also nicht zum Austausch privater Informationen, ist aber dennoch eine gute konzeptionelle
Demonstration von BB84. Zweitens haben echte Quantencomputer Rauschen. Selbst wenn Alices Vorbereitungs-
basis mit Bobs Messbasis übereinstimmt und kein Lauscher vorhanden war, gibt es noch eine kleine Chance,
dass sie aufgrund von Fehlern im Quantencomputer unterschiedliche Bits messen. Beim Vergleich
ihrer Bitfolgen auf Lauscher müssen sie eine gewisse Fehlertoleranz einplanen,
bevor sie schlussfolgern, dass jemand die Übertragung gestört hat und den ganzen
Schlüssel verwerfen. Mit diesen Einschränkungen starten wir nun ein Experiment ohne Lauscher.
Zunächst erzeugen wir zufällig drei verschiedene Bitfolgen, jede mit 20 Bits. Die erste ist Alices
initiale Bitfolge. Die zweite ist eine Liste der Basen, in denen Alice ihre qubits vorbereiten wird.
Dabei steht null für die Z-Basis und eins für die X-Basis.
Die letzte Liste enthält die Basen, in denen Bob jeden qubit messen wird. Anhand dieser drei Listen
können wir ein circuit-Diagramm mit Anweisungen für Alices Vorbereitung und Bobs Messungen erstellen.
Alle qubits beginnen im Nullzustand. Um ihre qubits in der Z-Basis vorzubereiten, tut Alice entweder nichts
für den Nullzustand oder wendet einen NOT- oder X-gate an – dargestellt als blaue Kästchen mit der Beschriftung X – für den Einszustand.
Für die Vorbereitung in der X-Basis wendet sie entweder einen Hadamard-gate an, der null in den Plus-Zustand überführt,
oder einen NOT-gate gefolgt von einem Hadamard, um den Minus-Zustand vorzubereiten. Dann sendet sie die qubits an Bob.
Die nächste Gruppe von Kästchen im circuit repräsentiert Bobs Messungen. Um in der Z-Basis zu messen,
muss er keine weiteren gates anwenden. Er misst einfach – dargestellt durch diese grauen Kästchen.
Um in der X-Basis zu messen, wendet er zuerst einen Hadamard-gate an und misst dann. Wir führen diesen
circuit mit dem Kisket Runtime Primitive Sampler aus, und die Ausgabe ist Bobs Bitfolge der Messungen.
Dann können wir Bobs Bitfolge mit Alices initialer Bitfolge vergleichen, die Bits weglassen,
bei denen ihre Basen nicht übereinstimmten, und sehen, dass beide denselben Schlüssel erhalten.
Denk daran: Das ist echte Hardware, also könnte es gelegentlich ein Bit geben, das eigentlich übereinstimmen sollte, aber nicht tut.
In diesem Fall stimmen alle Bits überein, aber wenn du das selbst nochmal ausführst, könntest du einen Fehler erhalten.
Solange die Fidelity aber nahe bei eins liegt, können Alice und Bob hinreichend sicher sein,
dass kein Lauscher dabei war. Schauen wir nun, was passiert, wenn Eve die qubits abfängt.
Jetzt haben wir zwei circuits. Der erste zeigt Alices Vorbereitung und Eves Abfangen und
Messung. Der zweite zeigt Eves Vorbereitung der gefälschten qubits und Bobs Messung. Wir können
diese circuits wie zuvor ausführen und dann sehen, was Alice und Bob beim Vergleich ihrer Bitfolgen erhalten.
Diesmal erhalten sie eine Fidelity von 0,6 Periodik. Das ist weit unter dem, was durch
Rauschen auf dem Quantencomputer erklärbar wäre – sie schlussfolgern also, dass Eve gelauscht hat. Quantencomputing
ist bekannt und wird oft wegen seines Potenzials zur Lösung schwieriger Probleme gehyped, aber Quantenkommunikation
und Kryptografie erhalten oft viel weniger Aufmerksamkeit, obwohl das Potenzial, das Quanten in
diesen Bereichen bieten kann, genauso bedeutsam und spannend ist. Heute haben wir das früheste bekannte Protokoll
zur Quantenschlüsselverteilung besprochen, das praktisch immun gegenüber unentdecktem Lauschen ist.
Wenn du selbst einen unknackbaren Code mit einem quantenzertifizierten Schlüssel senden möchtest,
schau dir das Modul in der Beschreibung an. Danke fürs Zuschauen, bis zum nächsten Mal!